and his tooth like falls out because my
hand got injured and i ended up in the
er that night ah coordination
something we all wish we had i did a
fight scene a few weeks ago
and twisted my knee on a mat
this includes the cast of kobrakai as it
turns out most of them are a little bit
klutzy and injure themselves or their
co-stars let's check out who took the
worst blows in the show
number one in a karate show this is
probably the least surprising injury now
this was a wild day for me and payton
mary mouser injured her hand so bad miss
blocking a kick she wound up in the er
she's never one to go halfway with
something she was warned by payton
list's stunt double janelle not to use
all of her force she really didn't need
to give much with this stunt with her
hands or she'd get hurt she just needed
to sell it when she pulled back i ignore
everything janelle told me and gave it
your all i gave it my all
she returned to set the very next day
all bandaged up and ready to film this
fight turns out she wound up
hyper-extending her tendons and after
filming wrapped she had to go for
physical therapy you can see certain
shots where my fingers are like taped
together and i'm like throwing punches
with them number two sure karate is fun
but wouldn't you rather just enjoy a
nice day of bird watching the pain
machio and zabka are dealing with has to
be because of their age they bruise
easier than they used to billy zabka
says machio's blocks feel like taking a
baseball bat to the arms
so with age comes responsibility
everything feels more connected than it
used to if you do a kick you feel it in
your neck so now they really take their
warm up seriously lest they feel it all
much more intensely later it's also
different filming for tv rather than a
movie and a little bit of
overworking but i am standing strong as
often they find themselves on a time
crunch so they don't even get half as
much time to rehearse their blocking
perhaps that's the reason why there's so
many injuries on set and it's so common
that the two hurt each other that they
call it getting machioed or zabkod
number three can twofer flinching please
be outlawed the funniest on this list
has to be how jacob bertrand was injured
by sholomereduena this one wasn't even
during filming it was totally just a
prank cholo was trying to play he really
wanted to make jacob flinch remember a
time when kids thought scaring each
other was fun
yeah we don't miss it either show low
proved to us exactly why it's okay to
flinch because if you don't
you could end up punched in the face
instincts are a good thing lest you want
blood streaming out of your nose number
four maybe braces should come with
little tiny shields
this is probably the most disturbing on
the list it hurts even thinking about it
jolo maraduena admits that while most of
the injuries on set are either hands
being stepped on or being kicked or
punched he was the first to be injured
pretty bad cholo received an accidental
kick to the face by tanner buchanan
what makes it so gruesome is that he had
braces at the time and the wire went
right through his cheek
it gets even crazier though because show
low didn't even notice
there was blood dripping down his face
and he couldn't tell are you cringing
right now at least he couldn't feel it
he said the part that hurt worse was
having the wire pulled back through his
cheek maybe there's still a visible scar
number five a toe jam pun will be
avoided but that is exactly what
happened here
secrecy on set about injuries is a big
no-no for you aspiring actor karate
warriors watching take your health
seriously billy zabka is pretty sure he
pulled a hamstring when his kick came in
contact with martin cove's buff foot but
that was the mild side of the story he
jammed it he broke it his toe went up
into his foot at least that's what could
be gathered from what he said the stunt
guy was ready to take his place but
billy pulled whatever was lodged up his
foot out presumably the toe bone he says
it felt akin to being knifed in the foot
oh wait
here
number six
she tells the story with such gusto
we're led to believe she enjoys causing
pain is anyone here
courtney hangler was on the very last
take of her scene with martin cove
whether it be the end of a long day or
what who knows but she got a bit
reckless that last time around and then
the great courtney let's do one more and
i did and i hid him in the face it was
her one stunt and she messed it up but
you know what you keep going you keep
acting because if you stop then not only
have you just hurt somebody but then you
ruined the shot that way the slap wasn't
for nothing her reaction as she
described it is priceless too in the
moment she's telling herself don't make
a face she was half successful because
this was the look she gave just to keep
going
number seven klutzes klutz is everywhere
mary mouser always finds herself covered
in bruises after working on cobra kai
but she admits that's due to her own
clumsiness she's not the only one though
as show low also admits to being a huge
klutz
number eight poor stunt doubles receive
way too many blows to the head while
we're sure the stunt doubles got injured
way more than once on this show sadly
they're not the ones who get the
spotlight but we did hear about this one
just because of how odd it was we throw
him on the ground and his face actually
hits the ground the poor guy really
whacked his head but by the sounds of it
was fine but he's not a noob in the
world of stunt doubling and has lost
some teeth in the past so can you
anticipate what happened his false tooth
actually fell out when he made impact
with the floor so everybody went on a
hunt for it hey tooth fairy quit
encroaching on the easter bunny's
tradition and find your own thing
don't worry eventually somebody found it
number nine
imagine walking in for your
run-of-the-mill work interview and being
tested on how well you know karate
that's how surprised peyton list was
when she found out she had to do it for
an audition she straight up admitted
that when she went for her audition she
had no idea she'd be doing any fighting
in this show
during the audition she was given 45
minutes to rehearse a fight sequence and
for somebody who's never fought before
she sure picked it up quick because it
got her the role
she's never sustained too many injuries
but she has owned the fact that bruises
are going to happen you'll get them
you'll give them and you can't feel bad
about it
number 10. today the world is telling
you to just stay in bed mary mouser
injured herself the second she stepped
out of bed i thought i was ready do you
remember that nursery rhyme about the
guy who went to bed and injured himself
it would have been a good day for mary
mouser to just stay in bed because she
experienced a stress strain on her ankle
and had to go film through the pain this
was the second injury she had to receive
physical therapy for after the show
wrapped
number eleven and you get an injury and
you get an injury and you get an injury
tanner buchanan spent most of a season
with a pulled hamstring it took him in
stride and did our best to keep fighting
both he and mary mouser were dealing
with injuries for quite a long time and
if you know anything about injuries you
can't just work through the pain yikes
i did what i had to do being part of a
show like cobra kai might just be worth
the pain for those awesome story arcs
the actors are handed which injury made
you cringe the most think there are more
inevitable ones along the way
let us know in the comments and thanks
for watching